[Musique]
salut à tous si vous suivez l'actualité
vous savez le monde musulman est souvent
secoué par des épisodes de tensions
entre les deux grands courants des slams
le cynisme et le sunnisme
mais quelles sont les différences entre
ces deux courants quels sont les
oppositions et bien c'est ce que je vous
propose de voir aujourd'hui d'abord d'un
point de vue historique puis théologique
et enfin politique mais d'abord quelques
précisions
sunnite
la tradition en arabe sous-entendu
tradition du prophète
car les sunnites se fie aux actes et aux
paroles du prophète pour élaborer leur
foi et fidjiens d'une expression
signifiant partisans d'ali un des
compagnons du prophète courant qui a
apporté ses propres dogmes en plus de la
sounna comme on va le voir le monde
musulman est composé de 85 et 90% de
sunnites et de 10 à 15% de chine est
présent principalement en irak et en
iran
maintenant passons à l'histoire à la
base la division chiite-sunnite découle
de la succession du prophète à la tête
des croyants mahomet en 632 sans avoir
d'héritier mâle et sans avoir nommé de
successeur aussi ses premiers compagnons
se réunir pour tenter de nommer un
nouveau chef qui sera censé être le
meilleur des croyants pour cela il se
base sur deux critères
il faut être parmi les premiers
convertis et attributs de la tribu du
prophète
parmi les successeurs potentiels se
trouvent aline cousin et gendre du
prophète époux de sa fille fatima est
souvent considéré comme le premier
convertis à l'islam alors qu'ils étaient
à peine adolescent ali estime que
mahomet voulait faire de lui son
successeur mais n'aurait pas eu le temps
d'officialiser sa décision il est vrai
que symboliquement le prophète lui a
donné son sabre mifid d'une fille car ce
qui peut être interprété comme une forme
de passation de pouvoirs et le
surnommait aussi le lion de l'islam mais
c'est aboubakeur un autre proche du
prophète qui est finalement désigné
comme successeur
suite à aboubakar deux autres qualifs se
succèdent laissant aller sur la touche
le deuxième osman fait du népotisme
favorise sa propre famille dans les
nominations officielles et finn est
assassiné ali accède enfin au califat
mais les choses se passent mal il est
contesté par d'autres branches de la
famille notamment par aïcha la femme
préférée de narbonnais qui est aussi sa
propre belle mère car on n'est pas dans
de l'affrontement théologique
ces querelles qui aboutiront à un
schisme sont alors avant tout des
querelles familiales
cela donne lieu à la bataille du chameau
dont ali sort vainqueur mais un
gouverneur de syrie mucha william qui a
été nommé par son prédécesseur et
cousins haussmann refusent de prêter
allégeance à al ahly officiellement
parce qu'elle refuse de venger la sman
laissant penser qu'il pourrait être
derrière l'assassinât et officieusement
c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'il craint
de perdre
un conflit éclate donc entre ali est
mort à millas mais les forces étant à
peu près égales les deux parties
décident de négocier elle y renonce au
khalifat après un accord dont les termes
restent contestés et se concentre sur
son rôle de guide pour ses partisans
mora où il ya lui accède au khalifat il
va instaurer la succession dynastique
écartant du choix du calife
la famille élargie du prophète c'est
ainsi que naît la dynastie des califes
omeyyades qui va régner sur l'islam
pendant un siècle
du côté fit à la mort d'ali hassan un de
ses fils prend la direction de ses
partisans et à sa mort son frère hussein
hérité du commandement morale où il ya
des cédants 680 son fils yazid du
succèdent mais hussein refuse de le
reconnaître comme calife voulant
rassembler ses partisans
hussein tombent dans une embuscade et
est exécuté vous en être un culte du
martyr après la mort du scène plusieurs
imams de la famille se succèdent à la
tête des chiites dont les trois derniers
auront empoisonné gens nous aiment imam
est censé ne pas avoir d'enfant mettant
un terme à la ligne mais très vite
apparaît la croyance en un fils qui
serait resté caché pour fuir la
répression
c'est ainsi que naît la croyance du 12e
imam caché toute sa vie cet imam appelé
mohammad al mahdi serait restée cachée
du régime sunnite transmettant ses
recommandations par le biais
d'intermédiaires
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'occultation
mineurs mais après 70 ans quatre
intermédiaires se sont succédé et pour
expliquer que l'imam restent cachés et
qu'il n'a pas de succession d'une
nouvelle croyance va apparaître celle de
l'occultation majeur l'imam est
maintenant censé rester caché jusqu'à la
fin des temps où il réapparaîtra pour
guider les croyants
on a là une modification majeure de la
croyance musulmane après laquelle al
islam chiite va se concentrer sur les
lignes et dali et lavaur en tout un
corpus doctrinal sur la sainteté de
celle ci ce qui nous amène à la question
théologique mais avant de passer à cette
partie il faut quand même dire que les
chiites saison globalement vécu
persécutés et caché connaître ont tout
de même deux périodes de règne en egypte
d'abord puis en iran où le schisme
deviendra religion d'état
si tout part d'une querelle de
succession le schisme religieux qui va
en sortir va faire naître deux islam
très différents différence qui se
traduisent jusque dans la chahada la
profession de foi musulmane
la chahada sunnite proclame qu'il n'y a
de dieu qu'allah et que mohammed est son
prophète
alors que chez les chiites elle met
également à lille en avant ali et sa
descendance ne sont donc pas de simple
ajout secondaire mais font partie du
coeur de la foi chiite
les douze imams vont être investis d'un
rôle divin avec nommé et sa fille fatima
ils forment les quatorze infaillible une
sorte de panthéon largement plus étendue
que pour les sunnites l'impiété est
aussi défini différemment défis peuvent
représenter le prophète pris les cinq
hommes les imams et font des pèlerinages
sur leurs tombes
par exemple le pèlerinage est plus
important est celui de kerbala où est
enterré hussein à l'occasion de la fête
de l'achoura qui commémore son martyre
les sunnites peu proscrivent
généralement toute prière à un humain
pratique vu comme de l'idolâtrie et
luttent contre par exemple le
gouvernement saoudien détruit des
monuments liés à des personnages des
écritures pour éviter qu'ils ne soient
des lieux de culte c'est le cas à jeddah
où les tombeaux qui est censé être celui
d'eve a été bétonné en 1975 il ya aussi
une différence dans la façon
d'interpréter le coran et les paroles du
prophète pour prescrire la loi les
sunnites reconnaissent quatre écoles
juridiques officiels qui ont une
interprétation plus ou moins stricte de
la loi divine alors que pour les chiites
selon l'un des douze imams peut
interpréter correctement la loi par sa
connaissance parfaite de la religion les
chiites n'ayant plus les imams pour
interpréter les textes religieux fondent
leur respect des règles islamiques sur
l'imitation des meilleurs musulmans via
leur époque à savoir certains ayatollahs
appelé marge à terme signifiant source
d'imitation
c'est un titre décerné par le haut
clergé et ses marges à sont très rares
et très influent
car chaque site de son choisir un tome
directeur de conscience auquel il se
référa quand il se posera des questions
religieuses également des différences
existent dans l'interprétation de la fin
des temps
chez les musulmans lors de la fin des
temps un peu comme chez les chrétiens un
faux messi est censé venir pour tromper
les croyants le date du lam
puis viendra le vrai représentant de
dieu le mahdi chez les chiites
le mahdi est assimilé au douzième imam
alors que chez les sunnites
on ne sait pas qui sera l'envoyé de dieu
et ce douzième imam et facilement
interprétée comme étant le d'hadjal à
plus forte raison quand on sait qu'il
est censé venir accompagné d'une armée
de juifs iraniens
en clair pour les fid les sunnites qui
se réfère au khalifat soutiennent des
usurpateurs et pour les sunnites et les
chiites sont d hérétique adepte d'une
fausse fois qui confine à l'anti
religion et bien sûr ces différences
théologiques ou entraîner des
différences politiques
il ya d'abord des différences dans la
structuration du clergé le clergé
sunnite n'est pas hiérarchiser les
oulémas interprète le coran et les
hadiths pour prescrire la loi mais
chacun est indépendant est le seul
dirigeant en théorie elle qualifs le
clergé chiite lui est très hiérarchisé
on parle de mola et d'ayatollahs le
terme imams étant plutôt associé aux
douze imams infaillibles
ces termes sont aussi utilisés par
certains pays sunnites proches de l'iran
par influence culturelle le clergé
chiite fait aussi la différence entre
descendants du prophète et non
descendant les religieux descendante
normes et porte un turban noir quand les
autres porte un turban blanc ensuite
chez les sunnites
celui qui dirige qu'il soit quel iphone
on est chef politique et spirituel il y
à confusion des pouvoirs dans la droite
ligne de mahomet qui était lui-même chef
spirituel politique et militaire par
exemple au maroc pays sunnite
aujourd'hui encore le roi est
officiellement le guide des croyants est
d'ailleurs mohamed 6 descend du prophète
par ali et fatima il pourrait donc se
proclamer qualif s'il le voulait par
contre les salles ou 2e qui défendent un
islam qu'ils estiment être le plus pur
et dirige le pays comportant les deux
villes saintes de l'islam ne descendent
pas de la famille du prophète
ce qui les embête bien pour asseoir leur
leadership sur la communauté musulmane
chez les chiites par contre il ya une
séparation entre le spirituel et le
temporel
le religieux ne devant pas se mêler de
la politique il y à cela deux raisons
d'abord historique comme ils ont
longtemps vécu leur foi café les
religieux dont l'ue a exercé que des
charges purement religieuse et ensuite
et surtout théologique
car le seul à même de diriger les
croyants de restaurer le califat
c'est l'imam caché il ya donc en théorie
une forme de laïcité possible avec le
chiisme et là je vous vois arriver
vous allez me dire et l'iran c'est pas
une théocratie chiite peut être oui tout
à fait effectivement en iran le
religieux dirigent plus ou moins
directement
il y as séparation physique entre
pouvoir politique et religieux n'est pas
la même personne qui exerce les deux
mais au final c'est le religieux qui
tranche en dernier ressort
via le conseil des gardiens de la
constitution qui est une sorte de
conseil constitutionnel le politique est
donc subordonnée aux religieux mais
cette organisation fait débat au sein du
cynisme est relativement récente
elle remonte à la fin des
70 et à l'instauration de la république
islamique d'iran on doit cette
subordination du politico religieux
arménie grand ayatollah fondateur de la
république islamique qui a développé une
théorie le gouvernement par le
théologien théorie stipulant que les
juristes religieux par leur connaissance
approfondie de l'islam sont les plus
aptes à développer une politique au plus
près de scorer fernie vannes
de fait c'est un rapprochement avec le
sionisme c'est une forme de khalifa qui
ne dit pas son nom
cette théorie a triomphé en iran et a
aussi été incorporé par le hezbollah
libanais et à côté de ça vous avez les
quetes east qui considère que le
religieux devrait retourner à sa place
hors du politique et que le gouvernement
par le théologien est une forme de
déviation c'est le cas par exemple d'
ali al-sistani plus importante ayatollah
irakien qui a d'ailleurs le titre de
marshall et qui veulent un état irakien
laïque mais la période actuelle est
favorable aux quais tistes avec un monde
de plus en plus multipolaire et philippe
comme tout le monde le peser
politiquement et affirmer leur identité
et fatalement ça passe par une forme
d'actualisation de leur rapport à la
politique comme le fond l'iran et le
hezbollah libanais voilà cette vidéo est
terminée j'espère qu'elle vous aura
permis d'y voir un peu plus clair dans
les antagonismes entre chiites et
sunnites
moi je vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine vidéo sur un tout autre sujet
d'ici là je vous dis portez vous bien et
à la prochaine
[Musique]